j'ai appelé mon père je dis papa et
qu'est ce que je pourrais me prendre
pour être plus en forme quoi unimail
adulte devra passer on rappelle que
votre père jean pierre castaldi qu'il
avait fauté tous pareils il m'a dit
écoute écoute il ya un truc qui marche
très bien si tu prends le tabasco
non c'est sûr qu'on en fait lui il a pas
but il a mis sur les jeunes et les
premiers jours au premier jour du mois
donc j'ai envie que chacun pour ce début
d'émission me raconte sa première fois
mais ça peut être son premier ce sera sa
première fois avec une fille a peut être
son premier jour de travail grâce à sa
première au bout il y avait quelqu'un à
valérie bénaïm c'est quoi alors ce qui
me vient à l'esprit c'est rien moi mon
premier jeu rostit catastrophique
d'arrivée alors vous aviez choper
d'ailleurs le prof de ski qui s'applique
david qui était canadien
je suis totalement nul au ski mais ça
m'a pas empêché de choper effectivement
elle a un très haut
il avait un très beau forte de ce
premier jour est restée dans les années
80 et donc à l'époque on avait des
combinaisons fluo vous souvenez un peu
et malheureusement l'amiénois elle était
orange et surtout elle avait 7 ce côté
matières toile cirée way est donc comme
je ne savais pas ce qui est je serai
sans poils histoire au-delà bild
évidemment je ne sais pas ce qui est
donc je jeu choix du choix hiver mais je
ne m'en fais pas je choix
alors oui et le problème c'est que avec
cette combinaison impossible de
s'arrêter
ce qui fait que j'ai été applaudi par
toute la piste qui devait faire au moins
je sais pas un kilomètre de kilomètres
on sait rien sur les fesses on n'est en
hurlant en essayant de m'arrêter avec
mes skis évidemment je des choses et je
glisse je glisse je glisse d'accord tout
le monde m'applaudit et j'étais la star
de la station eh bien écoutez une
mélissa me fait beaucoup de peine de
démarrer sous peu
ça vous tombe sur la gueule moi ce qui
me vient à l'esprit du coup c'est ma
première fois ma vraie première non ah
bah oui à du cul voilà j'avais douze
permis d' allah alors allez-y
alors votre première fois alors là je
vous demande et je le silence et
concentration
j'étais en terminale non mais c'est
mignon j'étais en terminale et j'étais
très très nul en maths
donc j'avais pris option maths il
fallait absolument que j'ai le niveau
pour avoir au moins la moyenne donc mes
parents m'ont forcé à prendre des cours
je croyais émettant forcé à coucher car
la cour cours particuliers de maths est
donc évidemment au début j'ai fait la
gueule j'ai dit attends c'est bon j'ai
pas que ça à faire laissez moi je me
débrouille etc
ils ont insisté pendant une partie de
l'année et finalement le jour est arrivé
où le prof de maths particulier petit
étudiants de 19 20 en maths sup
compagnie bon moi j'étais en bac
littéraire option maths traders sous la
glace avec un an de plus que moi et
quand j'ai vu arriver chez moi j'ai tout
de suite compris qu'on allait faire un
peu plus que des amis sion d abbas comme
terminal haj et les additions
chaque et caroline ithurbide quand elle
est sortie de shrek
j'ai déconné sur 10 pouces si je crois
que j'ai mes 14 maxime thoor la pape
allemand alors là le chef
alors là la première fois où je t'ai des
bouquets seul jésus était au départ
halloween lors c'est mon premier râteau
mon premier râteau à mon avis avec une
fille c'était il ya deux ans avec une
très jolie fille appelée comment vous le
ferez jamais eu de râteaux avant sa
vedette n'ont jamais vraiment jamais non
je ne me sens jamais combien de filles à
peu près 3 4 est toujours des histoires
très sérieuse mais c'est beau mais
j'aime bien ce n'est qu'en deuxième on
s'est mis avec les conflits margot
margot à 800 et bottes mais branché de
police était moderne à donner la
gougoutte ascenseur un peu aberrant
siècle où si tu as un référent fut alors
oui un peu de baranger le coup elle m'a
dit c'est une fille très ouverts d'asie
ok je lui dis prend prompt le resteront
que tu sois tu es bien sûr elle m'a
invité dans un bar avant moi qui ne
voient pas l'alcool j'ai passé une
excellente soirée avec mon verre d'eau
en tout cas l'assuré se passe bien je
sais me rendez vous au cinéma depuis son
slam burger justement si vous avez
décroché tapé mambo de mise et il faut
l'embrasser pour le deuxième rendez vous
donc j'étais focalisé sur ça j'écoute
est quasiment pas ce qu'il disait et
j'avais vraiment l'impression de devoir
l'embrasser on termine se paye
l'addition
on longe la rue on prend le métro à
opéra et dans le métro opéra ça pue
souvent lésés duels et les égouts pardon
et là je me levais à l'embrasser c'est à
dire une deux trois secondes et vous de
la troisième seconde elle sortit ali
mais qu'est ce que tu fais ça c'est que
j'ai dit non mais je mets tu n'étais pas
du tout prêt pour faire ça et depuis ce
jour
pourquoi je ne suis pas bon au drague
parce que ça m'a totalement tétanisée
donc voilà la petite histoire c'était
mon premier râteau c'était il ya deux
ans et c'était plutôt sympathique car
c'est un peu ripoux christophe carrière
est-ce que c'est intéressant bien oui
c'est intéressant c'est ma première fois
à la télé à bonson religion
[Applaudissements]
tu vois c'est la première fois qu'une
fille non non non non et en fait d'abord
une fois j'étais très stressée je vois
là je les ai bien quel âge
vgp à 14 ans quel âge vous la première
fois pierre 13 13 ans ah ouais après
j'ai une longue traversée du désert
ah oui j'ai beaucoup progressé en
travail manuel merci mille raisons
invoquées la joue ma 17
oui c'est vrai avec thomas 15 entre au
moins 28 jours trois mois va toujours
alors vous dont 14 en tant que trésorier
14 ans et j'ai j'avais peur de ne pas
être à la hauteur donc mais d'où la
chanson être à là et donc j'ai appelé
mon père je dis papa et qu'est ce que je
pourrais me prendre pour être plus en
forme quoi uni mail à vue et devra
passer rappelle que le père jean pierre
castaldi qu'il avait fauté tous pareils
il me dit quoi il écoute il ya un truc
qui marche très bien si tu pourrais
tabasco non c'est sûr qu'on en fait lui
il a pas but il a mis sur le secteur
il
hélas hélas normalement et a suivi mines
activées up easy ressemble un peu
rapidement d'espelette aux élus tabasco
évidemment au bout de deux secondes et
demi j'avais la quéquette on veut
marcher et le plus rare c'est qu'après
j'ai mis la faune est en feu de l'autre
bah oui oui ça a été un drame ans a
réussi quand j'avais appelé les pompiers
c'était c'était pénible cgtp débat est
bon on termine par une bien belle
anecdote
[Musique]